and tonight on our great great American
panel he is a democratic pollster Fox
News contributor Doug Shon is back with
us she is the founder editor and
publisher of Atlas shrugs dcom and
author of the brand new book The Post
American presidency the Obama
administration's war on America Pamela
Geller is back he is a former assistant
us attorney a senior fellow at the
National Review Institute author of The
Grand Jihad a New York Times bestseller
Andy McCarthy is also here all right um
Obama friends radical friends we're back
again uh now we had tried some time back
uh to get one time obam Confidant and
Professor Rashid khi and we tracked him
down for this
interview Professor khi hi Griff J is
the fox can I ask you a quick question
cannot ask could you just tell me what's
your relationship with Senator Obama so
we can clarify it
sir I apologize for interrupting but you
become the centerpiece of the election
will you at least call for the LA Times
to release the video excuse us please
what was said what was said at that
speech will you talk to us not were you
the spokesman for the PLO we confirm
that what was the relationship and what
was on the video well we don't know what
exactly was on the video except that
President Obama then uh a state senator
I believe gave a glowing tribute to
Professor khi he was on his way to
Columbia to take the Edward S chair in
Arab studies um also an an attendance
reportedly
uh was their other friend Bill s the
former Weather Underground terrorist my
buddy Bill SS and and what we understand
from it was that it was a a rapidly
anti-israel function uh as one would
expect in that setting I'm not accusing
President Obama of saying anti-israeli
things but uh he was there they were
said and we never got to see the tape
well one of the journalists that were
there and I have a large portion of this
in my book dedicated to khi did say he
said anti-israel things and it's
important to point out that anti-semitic
things yeah yeah anti-semitic things and
that uh Obama babysat uh the ked's
children when Obama sat on the woods
foundation with terrorist bill aairs he
granted 40,000 and $30,000 respectively
to uh
Rashid flotilla the Jihad warship
flotilla that he's raising money for uh
The Audacity Of Hope there is no way
that Obama did sign off on that and I'm
sure there's going to be plausible
deniability but we saw that same
deniability with lockerby and yesterday
broke that he knew about lockerby and
the you know I I and many others tried
to point out these radical associations
Doug beforehand you've got a pretty
hard-hitting column coming out he gave
me a sneak preview both you and padell
co-authored the piece it's going to be
what in the journal tomorrow in the
journal tomorrow yeah and we'll say it's
basically going to say that the one
thing that we hoped for from President
Obama whatever his policy positions were
that he would unite people that we'd
have a national conversation on Race we
wouldn't point fingers rush to judgment
divide and conquer and Pat and I say
look we're liberal Democrats we believe
in what the Democratic party stands for
but that's that's unity and common
purpose and vision not this divisive
politics what what about all these
radical associations I mean for example
should the president be taking a
position on the on this controversial
AMOM that wants to build a BOS Ground
Zero and what is your position well look
personally I am not for it the president
whether he takes a position or not is I
think his his judgment because it's a
local issue the larger question to me
really a local issue I think it is but
to me the larger issue is does the
president stand with our Democratic Ally
in the Middle East Israel do you think
he does I I think there's grave out I
think he took a small step in the right
direction in his meetings with uh Nyah
but bottom there are so many questions
yes so many questions in isra was a
photo op for the November elections
everything all the evidence points to
Obama's anti-semitic associations just
do you think the president's antisemitic
I do I don't think he's antic why would
that's a that's a hard charge it is a
hard charge but I say by their fruits we
shall know him and so we know him in
regards to concerning Israel and doing
nothing to stop the Iran bomb mom I I
tell you Sean as we admire the greatest
Generation for fighting Nazism uh our
children and our grandchildren will hate
us we'll hate us for leaving them
hostage to nuclear Rogue regime I've
said this on the air I get a lot of
email when I say it I think this is the
1930s in this what in this sense the
anti-semitic rhetoric worldwide is
hitting a a frightening frightening
level and when people continually talk
about wiping Israel off the map I
believe them what they're saying is they
want a Holocaust in our lifetime well
but but the more important thing to me
Sean and I I don't mean to minimize that
but Israel is the canary and the coal
mine for the American people and with
due respect Doug you know the that's not
a local issue the the uh the mosque MOS
Ground Zero what we're talking about is
do we understand the threat against us
which the people making the threat
against us which is a
mainstream uh movement in Islam mhm um
tell us quite forthrightly at least when
they're speaking among themselves uh
that they regard themselves as involved
in a Jihad to destroy Western
Civilization but this guy want Sharia
law in America but they want to destroy
us it's not just Israel we got to take a
quick break we will come back we will
continue more with our great great great
American panel straight
ahead and we continue with our Great
American we've talked a lot tonight
about all the tax cheats let's see gner
and and Charlie Wrangle and and John
Kerry and uh dou you're the Democrat on
the panel they're very generous with our
money how about they pwy up I think
there's enough malfant to go around I
don't think it's just liberals I think
you know that John KY why did he pay his
taxes look he said he's gonna anti up
now he's gonna anti up now called Tom
dashel anti up later
M long-term maintenance in Rhode Island
yeah no but it's the out the rich from
the 19th hle and care of his health
insurance before he became thear to
ration ours uh the the it's like Lloyd
Benson leaving that exclusive you know
club which then as soon as the the he
runs for VP he joins the club again it's
the establishment of the Elite Class
it's the EST aristocracy uh it is the
abandon mates and equal rights for equal
men it's the aristocracy it's the
narrative that liberals have created for
them stud uh they have a monopoly on
minority rights they care about the poor
Republic the rich they've done a pretty
good job reality you know they're the
ones spending all this money on uh
mismanaging but it takes it takes two to
tango take narrative if the media
doesn't ask them about not going to ask
then well but then that's what we the N
you know really Mal feance as I said on
the right and the left plenty of big
spending uh well something like this
it's moral showing for Obama and the
Democrats now is that the Americans
support that no no and and conservatives
don't uh that you know we're we're the
guy and Jack you have great respect for
as did I the Republican Administration
is the press for the dirt and here you
see a complete abandonment it's all the
things that they printed to these
left-wing journalists all right um we
were at Russia's wedding right by the
way wasn't that it was unbelievable
unbelievable what was amazing is that I
I don't think I've ever over a concert
where after every song he got a standing
ovation I mean he was it was a really
amazing night anyway Elton came out took
a very against uh artists that are
boycotting the state said he said uh
we're all very pleased to be with some
artists that they won't come here they
are exploit of wits I still play in
California as a gay man I have no le
people you know sh and John I've yeah
and I've been at his house and his
attitude is I'm for G rights but I'm
practical and rational and given the
conversation tonight what made me most
proud was he went to Israel after the
Flo and did did a progressive work in
the system in
after I saw him perform and after
listening to him I don't believe a thing
I've ever read about the guy yeah I have
I just have a whole different point of
view on him well but he's got an
entertain about you know all this
politics is so in our face all the time
when you can settle in with some who
doesn't want to hit you over the head
with their political views you know he's
there for a purpose you're to do with
politics was
impr he's such's such a I tell him you
said that pass that along he's such a
freak because they all line so to hear
somebody speak that that that's not a
leming that's not walking off that Cliff
everybody that's why it's the he does to
fight AIDS around the world anybody he
is a decent sincere man I got to tell
you and probably one of the most gifted
artists you know genius for Generation
he is a terrific performer no I just
think a year old PN Alec Baldwin yeah
guy's a great actor I can't stand him I
can't Elton John and Bill Clinton are
very close the best the best the best
piece of talk radio I ever heard was was
Alec Baldwin Philly in a wpht in Philly
uh uh um um um it was great stuff all
right guys thanks for being us all the
time we left this evening thank you for
being with us